[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
nothing really matters
nothing really matters
to me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
somehow i think you got to slow down
so careful not to show it
you really don't remember
[Music]
all the voices in your head
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
in your head
[Music]
uh
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
and you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
i think they got the aliens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
[Music]
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
jesus freaks
out in the street
handing tickets i've gone
[Music]
is
[Music]
looking she sings the song
[Music]
the word she knows
[Music]
oh i feel sorry lying here
with no one near only you
and you can't hear me
when i say softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
she's so bland
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dancing
[Music]
she's so blind
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you must see
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
in my hand
[Music]
[Music]
softly
[Music]
count the headlights
[Music]
today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
him today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
time to
[Music]
say
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
and so much space
but it wasn't because i didn't know
enough
[Music]
does that make me crazy
that make me crazy
[Music]
but think twice
that's my only advice
you really say you're in control
well i think you're crazy
[Music]
and all i remember is thinking
i want to be like that
[Music]
ever since i was little ever since i was
little it looked like fun
[Music]
but maybe i'm crazy
maybe you're crazy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
don't wish it away don't look at it
like it's forever
between you and me
i could honestly say that things can
only get better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before you
[Music]
[Music]
the blue
just here in the space
[Music]
[Music]
girl
[Music]
more than
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thunder
[Music]
[Music]
cry
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
undercover
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
please please please
please
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
got me wrong
[Music]
please please please
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i love you
[Music]
peace
[Music]
i love you so much
[Music]
when your day is tonight is yours alone
[Music]
are you sure
[Music]
don't let yourself go
[Music]
as everybody cries
[Music]
everybody hurts
sometimes
sometimes everything is wrong
now it's time to sing along when your
day is
[Music]
you think you've had too much
[Music]
cause everybody hurts
[Music]
[Music]
everybody hurts
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
oh
[Music]
days and nights
you think you care too much
[Music]
but sometimes everybody cries
[Music]
everybody hurts
sometimes
everybody hurts
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we got it together
i can easily feel myself slipping more
ways
[Music]
nobody but you and me
got it together
[Music]
myself
[Music]
that's what you are i know
there's only only one like you
there's no way they could have made two
yo you're all i'm living for
your love i'll keep forever
you're the first you're the last
[Music]
so many things
[Music]
you make me feel this way
i see so many ways that i
[Applause]
[Music]
you're my reality
yet i've lost it
hi everything
[Music]
[Music]
i know there's only
only one like you
there's no way they could have made you
girl you're my reality
[Applause]
you're the last
[Music]
you and me
you are the best
down
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
his righteous sentence
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
glory
speakers
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
please please please
[Music]
please
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
please please please please
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
baby take my hand
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i love your souls
[Music]
i love you so much
[Music]
time after time
i've done my sentence
[Music]
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've met a few
[Music]
are the champions my friends
[Music]
[Music]
i've
[Music]
i thank you
[Music]
i consider it a challenge
my friends
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
[Music]
and it met her still today
but there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to la
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american where
it
[Music]
[Music]
and is her still today
[Music]
who died
[Music]
still today
[Music]
thank you very much hello erie remember
that great victory we had
all
what a victory 14 days from now
we are going to win the commonwealth of
pennsylvania and we are going to win
four four years in the white house
with your vote we will continue to cut
your taxes
cut regulations support our great police
protect our second amendment
defend our borders keep jobs
and wealth in america where it belongs
thank you we will deliver record
prosperity
epic growth and you know that have you
seen what's been going on
how well we're doing did you see
the recent poll just came out 56 percent
of the people
want to be here not four years ago they
want to be with us
in what we're calling we're rounding the
turn on the pandemic
56 and it's a record
epic job growth safe vaccines
that quickly end the pandemic ending
normal life that's all we want you know
what we want
normal life
normal life will finally resume and next
year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country
[Music]
this is an election between the trump
super recovery which is happening right
now
and a biden depression if he gets
elected you will have a depression
the likes of which you've never seen
you know he's gonna double triple and
now quadruple your taxes i don't think
so i think i know the people of
erie pretty well they don't like that
it's a choice between our plan to kill
the virus or biden's plan to kill
the american dream and that's what he'd
be doing
biden will delay therapies postpone the
vaccine
prolong the pandemic close your schools
shut down our country and by the way
pennsylvania's been shut
down long enough get your governor to
open up pennsylvania
get your governor to open it up he will
massively raise your taxes
bury you in regulations dismantle your
police departments
dissolve our borders confiscate your
guns
second amendment oh you're so lucky i'm
president you wouldn't have a second
amendment
eliminate private health care terminate
religious liberty
destroy the suburbs i'm saving the
suburbs i knocked out the regulation
no you don't like projects being next to
your beautiful house your
american dream so much for the american
dream
and joe biden will ban fracking and
abolish pennsylvania energy
how many times did he say your fracking
and mining industries will be outlawed
exiled
eradicated and totally extinguished and
you know it
because it's not up to sleepy joe he's
gonzo
it's up to the others and the party joe
biden
has repeatedly pledged to ban fracking
right
you've all heard it have you heard it
till he got the nomination that he came
to pennsylvania he said oh
i guess it's okay it's always what they
say first
his running mate the most liberal member
of the u.s senate
sponsors the 100 trillion dollar
think of that 100 trillion if we had
a great year for a hundred years we
couldn't make a hundred trillion dollars
the 100 trillion dollar socialist green
new deal
which would eliminate fossil fuels at
this very moment biden's website
includes a pledge to mandate net zero
carbon emissions which means
he would end all fracking that's what he
said
he said it for a year and a half he said
it
under the obama biden administration
more than 40 percent of all coal mining
jobs will be destroyed totally gone
and you know what's happened i mean did
you see what they did to west virginia
and other places including pennsylvania
when they were here
don't forget they've been here for eight
years before me
if they did a good job i would have
never run i didn't need this
i didn't need this although we're having
a good time
and we're doing a good job
no but it's true they did a good job i
wouldn't have run
thank you thank you
[Applause]
this is a lot of
a lot of people
i always want the cameras to show they
never like to show they don't like to
talk about it
you can hear how big these crowds are
and by the way you know in all fairness
to eerie
all over the country makes you feel good
all over the country
the biggest crowds anyone's ever had
bigger than what we had four years ago
bigger oh when you have to watch you
have to watch what we do to 60 minutes
you'll get such a kicker
you're gonna get a kick out of it leslie
stalls not gonna be happy the democrat
party
hates frackie they hate call good
beautiful clean they hate american
energy and joe biden will
shut it all down he's going to tonight i
want to
do something i want to give you this is
an original donald trump
broadway play and i had it done
specifically
first time i've ever pulled it out i had
it done
specifically for the people of erie
because you guys like
energy you like being energy independent
do you like that
energy doesn't it we don't need all
these faraway lands and everything else
we are now energy independent
and we're going to keep it that way take
a look at this clip we had it made up
and i think you're like
first time i've ever done this right
first time go ahead wherever it is put
it up
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal and fracking
in the biden administration no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated and no more
subsidies
for either one of those i guarantee
we're gonna end fossil fuel
no more no no fracking i'd gradually
move away from fracking
and i think it's critically important on
day one that we end
any fossil fuel leases on public lands
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning crack
and what we don't show is his more
current version oh yes we'll have
fracking
and the fake news they don't do anything
about it they don't even talk to him
about it
but right now he's got bigger problems
than fracking i think
you know what it's called you know it's
called the laptop
from hell
[Applause]
to all the people of pennsylvania here
this warning
if biden's elected he will wipe out your
energy
industry you have a million jobs just
like he wiped out your steel industry
and i brought it back i brought it back
only by voting for me can you save your
fracking
in pennsylvania we are going to have a
great time because you are going to
reject
the radical left the united states
and i say it and i'll say it a thousand
times
the united states will never be a
socialist
[Applause]
[Music]
nation
[Music]
think of it here we are in erie people
as
far as the eye can see look at that let
me know it's incredible
it's a great honor it's a great honor
for all of us
we're all in this together we're all in
it
as long as i'm president we will remain
the number one producer of energy
anywhere in the world you know we're now
number one in the world with
pennsylvania
you texas we have some great how about
north dakota does a great job north
dakota oklahoma
so many different ohio does a phenomenal
job
phenomenal a couple of ohioans
and they have to have the fracking and
they have to have the energy and we need
the energy
and you know you looked at your car when
did you think you were going to see
two dollars a gallon and less you didn't
think you're going to see that that's
like a tax cut
and at the same time our energy industry
is
is vibrant last year i visited the shell
petrochemical plant in beaver county the
largest
investment in your state's history our
opponents will put it out of business
they want to put it out of business
i don't think that's a great idea joe
biden has made a corrupt mark in
exchange for his party's nomination
he's handed control of his party over to
socialists
i added another word communists
marxists extremists
and they're full of hate and rage and
scorn
for the middle class and for everybody
frankly for the middle class and for
everybody
the biden harris kamala you like kamala
[Applause]
i'll tell you did our vice president do
a great job
what a great job i said mike that was
too easy
but the biden harris agenda is projected
to slash the typical americans
income by six thousand five hundred
dollars
in the wall street journal today a
nightmare for pennsylvania family six
thousand five hundred dollars
and that's just cut it down what you
could be making if you do this and what
we're doing because
for the last 47 years joe biden has been
outsourcing your jobs offshoring your
factories
and selling out the american worker and
who knows it better than pennsylvania
look at all the empty hulks that you
still have despite all the jobs
we've brought back america lost 10 000
factories while he was vice president he
has no clue by the way
just so you understand he has no clue
how many oh that's okay
he's a servant of the globalist
lobbyists wealthy donors
and washington vultures who got rich
bleeding americans
you know i said the other day i never
thought of it because they're raising a
lot of money 300 million
i could be the king of all fundraisers i
would be the greatest that ever lived
the president of the united states
all i have to do is give me a list of
the top 100 companies i'll call the
president of everyone
they will pay me whatever i want i would
set every record
the problem is i'd owe them because when
they call and they have a problem
for a lot more money than we're talking
about you know
it's like hard to say hey they were nice
they treated you good
i don't want to do that i don't want to
do that we don't need the money
i don't want to do that i don't want to
go
but when you see them raise 300 350
million dollars in a month and a half
you know deals are being made just so
you understand deals are being made big
deals
bills i mean look at the deals that he's
making for himself okay
but deals are being made in 2016
pennsylvania voted to
fire this depraved political
establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting
america first america
the fact is whether you like it or not
whether you want to hear it or not
joe biden is a corrupt politician
smoking gun emails show that the
biden family sold the vice presidency
for a very
very substantial amount of money more
money than anybody would believe
he let china plunder your jobs while his
family raked in millions of dollars from
china and foreign nations
the bidens got rich while pennsylvania
got robbed and so did the rest of our
country
if biden wins china wins if biden wins
china will own the usa and you know it
there's no way he does anything about it
and yet media and the big tech
big tech they're desperately trying to
cover up everything they don't want to
hear speeches like this they don't want
to hear anything about it
this is a massive scandal that they're
trying to suppress
i'm not just running against biden
sleepy joe i'm running against the
corrupt media
the big tech giants the washington swamp
and the democrat party is a part of all
of them
every single one of them they flood your
communities with criminal aliens
drugs and crime while they live behind
beautiful
gated compounds they try to take away
your gun
second amendment they want to take it
away
while they enjoy private security that's
fully armed
they support crippling lockdowns like
your governor is doing
while their jobs and their industries
remain
totally exempt and it's time to send a
message to these wealthy liberal
hypocrites
by delivering joe biden's sleepy joe
a thundering defeat on november 3rd
gotta get out and vote pennsylvania you
got to get out of vote
you know if we win pennsylvania we win
the whole thing
[Applause]
i mean it's crazy they're saying oh it's
his home state it's not his home state
he left you when he was nine right his
parents i'm not blaming him for that
but you know he likes to go around yeah
yeah oh it's my home so it's not his
home state
i actually went to college in
pennsylvania okay so you know i think i
have more in common
but it's not his home state he comes
from a place called delaware and he
never leaves delaware i like delaware
too
but he never lives here he's making
another speech from where doesn't make
too many speeches either
he took a five-day lid you know what a
lid is i never heard lid
lid is like they put the lid like a
garbage can right they put them
he took a five day lift i mean this guy
all he does is like
stay home you know why
you know why because he can't take any
questions now from the press can't take
any questions
how about yesterday he finally went
outside he went to get an ice cream
and the press is standing these are all
killers i mean there they are look they
think it is
they're standing
and all they wanted to know think of me
they're screaming at me like
all they want to know what flavor ice
cream do you like well i like
i like vanilla and chocolate thank you
they don't ask me those questions
if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
and if i don't always play by the rules
of the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and nobody
has ever fought for you harder than i
have that i can tell you
i'm fighting so hard because i love my
country i love you by the way but i love
my country
thank you thank you thank you
and this is a tough group in front the
last time
the last time they said that last time
this guy said that to another man i
doubt you have maybe dead maybe dead a
long time ago
but because i'm determined to ensure
that the forgotten men and women of this
country remember
they showed up four years ago and
they're showing up now you see what's
going on
do you see the lines do you see what's
happening all over the country
they still don't want to report it they
know what it's going to be this is going
to be
bigger than four years ago there's more
enthusiasm
the crowds are bigger they'll never
be forgotten again not after this one
they tried to find out who are all these
people that showed up last time now
they're finding out again except even
more so
no you see what's going on though with
the lines and everything and then they
have the phony fake ballots all over the
place
they're throwing them in the garbage can
oh they happen to have the name trump on
them isn't it
how about the ones that were printed
without my name on it right
they had everything on it they had every
race they had everything you had the
senate you had everything
they forgot to put me down oh thank you
and then they say he's against freedom
ah it's wild the biden-harris war on
police
would be a catastrophe
for public safety you know i think i
have every single
correct good i like that
[Applause]
i think we have every single endorsement
even
new york's finest new york city's finest
we love our finals
[Applause]
is the mic ready yes
[Music]
i wonder who did that to our mike
[Applause]
i don't believe it was joe you know who
it was
crooked hillary my son
i think it was probably crooked hillary
but kamala kamala by the way
she will not be your first
woman president she will not be can't
let that happen
there'll be a woman president you cannot
let that happen
harris even urged their supporters to
donate to a fund that
bailed out riders right out of jail
including
attempted cop killers i will
always stand with the heroes of law
enforcement so will you
[Applause]
and biden's policies would also decimate
our seniors biden is pledging
mass amnesty and free federal health
care remember he did that at
a stage you remember look she's shaking
her head she remembers
remember when he put up his hand
you know after 47 years he knew it was
not the right thing to do but everybody
else was raising you know they're all
radical left and he felt very
uncomfortable but then he looked he
looked over here looked over there they
were all over the place these people
they were all running for this beautiful
office
and he just got the hand up and i said
thank you we just won the election
and look we all have a heart you know
but what happens is everybody comes in
everyone's gonna we're gonna have
millions of people pouring into it they
get free health care
they get free college they get a rose
they get a rolls royce everybody gets a
free rolls royce remember when i said
that and cnn went crazy
he knows they don't get a free rolls
royce he lied to the american people
oh these are sick people thank goodness
they're ready to sin and ratings did you
see them
they're so bad fredo all these people
the ratings are so bad
their ratings are terrible thank
goodness
but he will obliterate your medicare
your social security i will always
protect your medicare
and your social security as i said for
you
i'm also proud that here in pennsylvania
your medicare
advantage you know that everybody have
it some people have it
the premiums have decreased listen to
this under our management
43 since i took office where do you hear
that
we will always defend our seniors and we
defend them like nobody else can
the battle against the china virus the
china virus that's what it is it's a
china
you know they call it kofi they call it
all different names
it's the china viruses or the china
maybe the china plague
we launched the largest mobilization
since world war ii
i'll tell you what the way they cover it
we have done such an incredible we saved
millions of lives
they refused to cover not for me but for
the people
the admirals the generals mike pence
everybody that worked so hard on this
and they refused to acknowledge it
we made a lot of really bad governors
look good and some good governors do
just fine
but a lot of bad governors we made them
look good early on
we took aggressive action we saved so
many lives
remember it was supposed to be 2.2
million under a scenario could have been
more than that
i took rapid action to ban travel from
china and from europe
heavily infected areas and by the way
the scientists said oh don't do it two
years two months later they were saying
lucky he did do it biden opposed both of
these life-saving
decisions you remember he said he's
xenophobic
i said joe joe what does it mean joe
couldn't answer he goes
only in pennsylvania he goes he does it
i'm well you're right about that
we pioneered incredible therapies excuse
me here i am
[Music]
that was quick that was quick now great
doctors we have great doctors and
reduced the fatality rate
85 think of that
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm working to make the antibody
treatment that i received available to
anybody that needs it
free and it's getting very close to
getting approved we will have
100 million vaccine doses before the end
of the year
maybe sooner than that maybe
substantially before
the biden lockdown he's willing to lock
you down you guys aren't even
open yet what the hell is going on with
your state
you know florida's open all this florida
had a surge
great governor serge went down arizona
had a surge went down great governor
texas had a surge went down
you guys never open
the hell is going on in pennsylvania
right
[Music]
the biden lockdown will crush america
we will crush the virus we're doing that
we'll crush you in the virus
look at our numbers compared to europe
you know they always said oh europe
europe
look at our numbers compared and we had
the biggest
of of any country the biggest comeback
we came back
faster we went down less economically
came back faster if you want depression
doom and despair vote for sleepy joe
biden
and boredom you know the great thing i
always say someday these people look at
all of them back look at all those
cameras
you know what i say someday they're
going to get smart they're going to
endorse president john
because if you had sleepy joe then
nobody's going to be interested in
politics anymore that's going to be the
end of that
they will all go out of business they
should have gone out of business four
years ago then i came along
if you want open schools an open economy
and a safe healthy thriving country
vote for me we're going to do it we're
doing it now we're doing it now
we're joined today by a few of my
friends i'll tell you this one guy
he got it right from the beginning
that's right how did you know that
he's a warrior he's tough as hell he
could have only been grown
in pennsylvania because he's that kind
of a guy
he said a long time ago when i knew him
it was a year before the election
and i said this is four years plus one i
said uh
how do you think we're going to do he
said sir you're going to win he said how
the hell do you know that i just started
the escalator ride wasn't too old right
the famous escalator with our first lady
they love our first lady
wasn't too old
we had just come down and a man named
congressman mike kelly said sir you're
going to win in a landslide
come up here mike come on
come on get out of here get up he can he
said i can't i can't do it again
they'll figure it out don't hurt
yourself though much don't prove
everything mike just hey fellas could
you help
the man he said you know just give me
here take your time
don't don't hurt yourself can you
imagine he's trying to climb over a
barrier to show that you
we don't want to hurt our mike he's been
right from the beginning he's been with
me
[Music]
great guy come here and also
my pennsylvania campaign chair done a
fantastic
really a fantastic job bernie
comfort bernie thank you great job
great job
don't touch me mike we'll get in trouble
with the media they'll say they touched
each other oh do you ever see this if he
would have done that i saved you mike i
saved maybe i saved your political
career
they would have had front page story of
our two hands touching
mike sayfield
[Applause]
[Music]
in our lifetimes we will never see a
president
like donald j trump again
i want every one of you to make a
commitment
to get out and vote november 3rd and
absolutely refuse
to lose
this is the president this is the time
this
is your solemn oath to america we're
going to make america great again
again because of donald j trump
there's no flu that's going to keep this
man down
he makes the energizer bunny look like a
deadhead
this guy never stops he never sleeps he
is totally dedicated
to each one of you and we should be
totally dedicated to him
i love this president i love his agenda
and i love the fact that on november 3rd
we're going to put him back in the white
house mr president
thank you
what a great job that was not a bad job
not a bad job not him he's a great guy
though he really is you're lucky to have
him
good job you know he shows up without
the jack and i feel a little like guilty
mike you're not called mike i hope right
don't be too brave we got to keep him
around right mike thank you mike great
job i appreciate it
under my administration we built the
greatest economy
in the history of the world and now
we're doing it again
in my first three years we increased
family income
over six thousand dollars listen to this
more than five
times the gains in all eight years
under the previous administration think
of that
in just a short period of time african
american unemployment
hispanic american unemployment and asian
american unemployment
all reached their lowest levels in the
history of our country
think of that
we lifted nearly seven million americans
out of poverty
a record including nearly 1.2 million
african americans out of poverty since
april
just since april just now
we created a record never happened like
this
11.4 million brand new
american jobs that's never happened
before
and you know you were hearing it sounds
terrible to me when i say it but
you were hearing about 38 unemployment
right 38 you're hearing 42
so it was i'll take us fake news
fortune thank hey thank goodness
but you know what it was two weeks ago
7.8
now 7.8 well we're at 3.4 and 3.5
i don't like to say 7.8 but when you
think about it they were saying we're
going to 42
you know not our fault we had this
plague coming from china
we're going to 40 42 38 13.
7.8 and heading down rapidly
that's pretty amazing when you think
about it
under biden it took 30 months to recover
more than half
of the jobs lost in a crisis we did it
in less than five months
[Music]
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage
joe biden inflicted over the last 47
years you saw what he's done
you know it's amazing he's always like
you know it's not him he's not being
critical
but he has writers they say oh let's do
this that you know i have all this stuff
vice president biden said he has no idea
what he said
but you know what i get he just you know
he didn't leave long ago
he was here for eight years as vice
president and 47 years plus
as a politician in washington think of
it and he's always like
why didn't he do this why why the hell
didn't he do it he just you know
why didn't he do it 47 years
joe why didn't you do it he supported
nafta
tpp which would have destroyed your
industry and china's entry
into the world trade organization
one cruel betrayal after another it's
true
i mean what he's done for decades our
politicians spent trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars and defending
foreign borders now we're doing love
orders do you like that better
but now we're finally protecting our
nation rebuilding our cities and we are
bringing
our jobs our factories and our troops
our beautiful beloved troops
we're bringing them all back home it's
time
19 years
[Applause]
to save our auto industry i withdrew
from the last administration's
trans-pacific partnership
pennsylvania gained michigan auto
factories auto plants being built all
over michigan
ohio there wasn't a plant built in 42
years now they're being built all over
the place
in japan i told the prime minister you
have to give us plants you got to get
you can't just keep sending us cars you
got to make them over here
and they started and you're a big
beneficiary of it to defend our steel
that aluminum workers
i impose very historic tariffs
on dumped steel right
and that hap and and you are still all
of your places started doing great
i ended the nafta nightmare and signed
the brand new
usmca just kicked in
[Applause]
you know how i know it's good because
the other two countries aren't so happy
that's good
they took advantage of us for a long
time i took the toughest ever action to
confront
china's rampant theft of american jobs
nobody
has ever done and you know what we were
nobody's having anything like this to
china
we would take it we're taking in
billions right now we're taking in
billions
billions and billions of dollars it
affects you a little bit we gave 28
billion dollars to our farmers
because they were targeted by china and
that was just a small fraction of what i
took in
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure
border southern border in u.s history
so we're building 10 miles you know the
wall
is going to be completed very soon and
we had
radical opposition to the wall radical
opposition
will be at 500 miles very soon and we'll
be completed with the wall
and by the way mexico you know they keep
saying mexico is paying for the wall
they understand that
they're paying for the wall mexico's
paying for it and it's very high
just like i said it would be and it
actually goes down very deep you know
why
two reasons actually number one to hold
it up number two to stop
the tunnels my opponent's immigration
plan
is the most extreme proposal ever put
forward by a
presidential candidate biden would
eliminate u.s
borders how about that do you like that
idea
okay just think of it from a brag how
the hell do you have a country if you
don't have borders he would eliminate
and you know that's signed in the
manifesto with bernie sanders crazy
bernie
bernie's one of the i'll tell you what
he's one of the greatest losers and i
mean that in a very nice way
twice they took it away from them right
hillary took it away and then elizabeth
pocahontas warren took it away
because she stayed in on super tuesday
she took enough votes away so he didn't
want any states
and then he goes back to the senate like
nothing happened this guy he's
i think he should be given you know in
school when i was a young guy in school
sportsmanship of the year i never
happened to receive that
i got other awards i never got the best
sportsmanship award
but bernie sanders should be given
sportsman of the year
sportsmanship i guess right no no it's
amazing this happened to him twice
is bernie running again in four more
years bernie are you running again
crazy burning but no but they signed
that you know they didn't sign i guess
they have this deal to manifesto they
agree
biden would eliminate and she's more
liberal than him you know
she's more liberal and there's nobody
that treated biden worse
than kamala that's why i said why would
he ever pick her
there's nobody that treated him worse
biden would eliminate u.s borders by
implementing nationwide catch and
release
which i ended if it's okay with you you
know what i did
you catch them what do you do they're
murderers
they're rapists you catch them and then
you have to release them this is called
catch this is a serious
this was a democrat program headed up by
crying chuck schumer he's the one
you catch them cry and chop
he only cries when it's i've known him a
long time the only time he cries is when
it's necessary
crying no no you catch them and you
release them into the country
and you say in four and a half years
please come back for a trial
nobody comes back a couple of really
stupid ones come back other than
making every community into a sanctuary
city
and suspending all removals of illegal
aliens they want to suspend
in this manifesto no more moving out
illegal aliens even if they're really
bad including
no violent criminals you catch ms-13
can't move them out
thank you very much we're living with
them this is what this is what these
people want
this is the most important election in
the history of our country look
you know we can play games and we can be
nice and we can have a good time
you think i need to be standing out here
in 50 degree weather
looking at mike in a shirt and he's
and he feels better about it than i do
right mike now this is this is the most
important
election in the history of our country
we cannot
allow we cannot allow this to happen
we're going to win we're going to win so
big i think we're going to win
you know the lines
the lines are record-setting
the lines are big the lines are big
there's a lot of
a lot of trump trump you know people
that a lot of people great americans
they never liked
who they were voting for they didn't
vote they just didn't vote
and they're online right now there are a
lot of people out there and it's looking
good it's early but it's looking good
get out and vote most important election
mic we've ever had i really believe it
and you know what four or five months
ago when we started this whole thing
because you know before the plague came
in i had it made
i wasn't coming to erie i i mean i have
to be honest there's no way i was coming
i didn't have to i would have called you
and said hey erie you know if you have a
chance get out but we had this thing won
we were so far up we had the greatest
economy ever greatest jobs greatest
everything
and then we got hit with the plague and
i had to go back to work hello erie
may i please have you a vote
[Applause]
right i love erie no hey we had a big
deal in erie
we had a big deal in the area right this
was not supposed to be a
trump thing it's a lot of democrats but
the democrats that love trump because i
love them and you know what
you're workers you're like we work we
work we work
but that was a pretty big upset wasn't
it huh big
big upset but if biden wins
your borders are gone which means your
health care is gone
the middle class is gone your safety is
gone
your country is gone that's what's gonna
happen
i don't think it can happen take a look
at venezuela this could be
same ideology as what they're talking
about this could be
a venezuela but much much much bigger it
can happen
it could happen you see these people you
see what they're saying
you see portland where they have
anarchists through the streets
and it's all democrat run areas no
republican areas
it's all democrat run areas that's where
you have
with portland it's anarchist but look at
the various
look at what's happened to our beautiful
new york since i've been gone think of
it
you know what it's like three and a half
years
if you think of it i think what i can
say is
if i would have stayed in new york that
wouldn't have happened it's very
interesting but look at what's happened
to new york in a few years
what's happened to new york what's
happened to chicago look at what's going
on in baltimore and just remember this
with obama biden they had nothing but
problems
look at baltimore remember how bad that
was ferguson
look at st louis look at oakland look at
all the problems you know they act like
oh it was so it was horrible
and you know i say it all the time if
they were any good
i wouldn't have run and if they were any
good if i did run
i couldn't have won right but they were
no good they did a rotten job they did a
lousy job
and joe is not equipped right now no
longer
he never really was you know he we used
to call him one percent joe and that was
in prime time
how about this and in non-prime time he
ends up getting the nomination figured
that one out
to secure our border i took the corrupt
media we had to take it on and they are
corrupt the powerful special interests
and the open borders lunatics because
they'll destroy our country in just
three years we removed over a half a
million criminal aliens including those
charged or convicted of more than 145
000 assaults 40 000 sex crimes
and 6 000 murders 6 000 murders
we got them the hell out some we had to
keep because we didn't even want them
out they were too dangerous
because we don't want them coming back
and i want to thank ice
and i want to thank our great border
patrol always law enforcement
but i support it
[Applause]
under a biden administration these
criminals would be set free
under my administration these criminals
are sent home or they have to be put in
prison
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military
we now have the greatest equipment we've
ever had
we are the envy of russia and china and
everybody in the world we have the best
missiles and rockets and tanks
and planes f-35
stealth you can't see it other than that
it's not so great
you can't see it i went to one of the
pilots i said how good is this plane
well it's really good
why is it good because the enemy can't
see it i said i don't know too much
about what you do
sounds good to me and for our great
veterans we passed
va choice and va accountability
we killed the leader of isis al-baghdadi
we killed the worst
mass murderer terrorists in many many
generations salamani is dead
[Music]
killed many soldiers many people i
withdrew from the last administration's
disastrous
iran nuclear deal by the way if and when
we win
my first call is going to be from the
heads of iran
and they're going to say let's make a
deal their economy
went from being strong they were all
over the world terrorism
now their economy is totally tanked with
our sanctions and other things
and they're down gdp think of this gdp
down 27
nobody's ever even heard everybody they
and i don't want that
i want them to be a good cell they
cannot have a nuclear weapon
they cannot have a nuclear weapon but i
want them to be good
i want them to be strong i want them to
have a great country the first call
will be iran as soon as we win they're
going to call
and we'll make a deal and others will
also call
they're all hoping china oh china china
wants us to
oh china they want they want joe biden
so badly you have no idea
they want they are dying for jobi
the one they don't want is they don't
want trump they've had enough of trump
tens of billions of dollars we get
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
we don't want trump please we've had
enough of trump
let's try somebody new this isn't
working now hey look
china has ripped us off more than any
country
in history and by the way plenty of our
allies rip us off too between trade and
military and everything else like you go
into that
i could speak about that all night long
but nobody
has ripped us like china for many many
long before obama
in all fairness and biden long before
then
they've ripped us off where's hunter i
don't know that's a good thing
where's hunter remember we said that
where's hunter that we made the t-shirt
it was the number one selling t-shirt
where's hunter what happened to hunter
where's hunter i also recognized
israeli sovereignty over the golan
heights
52 years they tried to do it i did it in
about two hours i even got nominated for
three nobel peace prizes
[Applause]
and for all different things one's the
middle east now one is
kosovo serbia you know we're doing a
deal with these countries i say
you guys have been fighting and killing
each other if we're doing a deal let's
get them to be like
let's not kill each other and we worked
out a deal a beautiful economic deal
between two
places that just killed each other for
years and years
and it just seems so easy and so natural
right
anyway in the middle east instead of all
of the blood
pouring all over the sand we're ending
all of that and you see what's happening
countries are joining
left and right no blood we did it a
different way
we did it how many times was i
criticized he can't get it done that way
you see this guy
john kerry who's grossly incompetent
only time he ever left the negotiating
table was to go into a bicycle race he
was 73 years old
and he fell he broke his leg in his arm
other than that it was a wonderful day
riding a bicycle and i pledge that i
will never be in a bicycle race okay
i did more in 47 months than joe biden
did in 47 years that's true
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities great jobs
and a limitless future for all americans
a vote for republicans and a vote for me
is a vote for the american dream that's
what it is it's a vote for the american
dream
and in conclusion we'll make this a
little shorter you know it's like about
40 degrees i don't want people i don't
want to lose anybody you got to go vote
so we're going to go a little shorter
because you got to go vote and i see
uh even mike he's so brave he started to
freeze his ass off
he said okay look i've proven my point
let's say president let's get me the
hell out of here
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all we're already doing
that
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults or law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second amendment
and if they get in you will lose your
second amendment remember that when
you're getting ready to
press trump we will strike down
terrorists who threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of these
ridiculous
horrible endless wars they're endless
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency already signed starts
on january 1st it'll be bigger than
healthcare watch this
and further reduce the costs of
prescription drugs which i've done
you know with favorite nations the drug
companies do not like me too much
you will have drug prices going down 50
60 70 80 percent could you imagine if he
were
in this position and people would go up
to him uh mr president you've done a
great job on drug prices oh really what
happened
they're down 82 sir really i can't
believe it
you better give me the credit damn it
i'll tell you what i put
what i've gone through the drug
companies they're spending a fortune
on fake ads they don't want me they
don't want me
china doesn't want me
iran doesn't want me nobody wants it
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody
eerie eerie wants me eerie ones
[Applause]
and will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions always
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to land
an astronaut on mars that's already
moving along
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our schools right
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national our great
national motto it'll never be changed
you know they want to
change that you know they want to take
certain words out like
the word god okay
[Applause]
in god we trust will always keep it
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
pennsylvania
always will great state great place
lot of friends so get your friends get
your family
get your neighbors get your co-workers
get your boss straight get your butt
come on boss we got to vote
and get out and vote you know you tend
to vote
very late which is good i understand
that before you know it's just the norms
and you tend to vote late get out and
vote
get out and vote this is the biggest
election of our lifetime get out
and vote from scranton to allentown
from pittsburgh to harrisburg and from
easton
to right here in erie we stand on the
shoulders of red-blooded american
patriots
who poured out their hearts sweat and
soul to secure
liberty and defend our freedom
pennsylvania is the state where our
founding fathers declare
american independence think of it
pennsylvania think of what you
represent as a state what state honestly
and we can say it to
the other states i love them they've
been great to me they voted for us
everything
but what states done some of the things
that
have taken place in pennsylvania it's
where the army
weathered its brutal winter at valley
forge
where general george washington led his
men
on a daring mission across the delaware
and where our union was saved by the
incredible heroes
at gettysburg right i mean who can say
these things
and and these names right gettysburg
these names
this is the place where generations of
tough strong
pennsylvania miners steelers factory
workers
forged the greatest nation in the
history of the world
and believe me the best is yet to come
it's coming it's all happening
the best is yet to go
proud citizens like you helped build
this country and together we are taking
back
our country we are returning power to
you
the american people we are returning
power to you and i said that a long time
ago when we started
it was being taken away i just didn't
know quite how deep the swamp was it's a
little deeper
a little more treacherous than i thought
but we're beating them
oh well they their head will explode on
november 3rd can you imagine
and then you know what's going to happen
you know what's going to happen
i think they're finally going to say
okay that's enough
let's go i think by that time they're
gonna they're gonna have it
they will have had it he goes they
better
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
and winning
[Applause]
[Music]
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible and i
mean that i know you well
a lot of time in this incredible land
this beautiful place this place of
history
the incredible people of pennsylvania we
have
made america powerful again our military
never been like this
remember at the beginning when the
overrated general said to me
sir we have no ammunition i said no
president should ever have that
no president should ever hear those
words sir we have no ammunition
we now have so much ammunition that even
mike would be impressed
[Applause]
so we've made it powerful again we've
made america wealthy again stock market
new
records your 401 k is everybody happy
with their 401k
you want to see your 401ks crash it was
on today
varney varney you know stuart he had a
gentleman on he said you know
if trump gets in the market's going to
go through the roof
if trump loses and this other guy gets
in
you're going to have a problem like
you've never seen before and i agree
your 401ks your stocks
you want to see him drop like a rock if
you want to have some fun with your
family
explaining why is it down 80 dad
we don't love you anymore dad
now your 401ks are doing great
everything's doing great we're going to
be in a position very soon
like we've never been in even better
than we were a year ago
we've made america strong again we have
made america proud again
we have made america safe again and we
will
make america great again thank you very
much pennsylvania
go out and vote go out and vote thank
you pennsylvania
thank you
[Music]
there's no need to feel down
there's a place you can go i say to your
[Music]
it's fun
[Music]
[Music]
is
but
[Music]
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was once
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ymca they can stop
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
why
i was down
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
i
[Music]
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
jesus freaked
out in the street
and then tickets have begun
[Music]
is not that bad
[Music]
she sings the song
to where she knows
[Music]
i feel sorry lying here
with no one near only you
and you can hear me
when i say softly
[Music]
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dance
[Music]
she's
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
blue
[Music]
[Music]
you must
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
a tiny dancer in my head
[Music]
when i say softly
[Music]
is
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you